in the Eastern French city of Haas
France's interior Minister jehal
darmanas surveyed damage from recent
unrest and met police more than 40 000
police officers have been deployed in
France in recent nights darmana said it
was thanks to them that the situation in
the country is karma
there were almost 300 municipalities in
France that experienced this kind of
violence but there aren't places that
usually see this sort of urban unrest
the national and Municipal Police did
what they had to do in the first few
days and we can see the result
country people gathered fed up with
unrest that's destroyed personal and
public property and put lives in danger
this Paris suburb Mez home was set on
fire
they wanted to murder my wife and our
two young children in their sleep and
burned them alive by trying to burn down
our house
the violence that followed the killing
of 17 year old nail by a police officer
last week seems to have subsided unlike
the French government's problems that
are far from over
in the Paris suburb of nonte where Nile
lived unemployment and poverty are
widespread opportunity scarce and some
young people say the police harass them
will continue to urge the state and the
government to do all they can for us
here and we'll continue to fight for
equality and social justice for
non-terror this town that we are also
attached to
more than 200 Mayors are scheduled to
discuss their concerns with the French
president at the Elise on Tuesday a
meeting that come six years after
Emmanuel macron was elected and promised
to help France's poorer neighborhoods
saying no one would get left behind a
promise many here say has yet to be
fulfilled Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
Paris